[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à tous dans ce nouveau
débat en ce jour de printemps nous avons
choisi de parler des eaux alors il
évoque pour beaucoup d'entre vous
sûrement de beaux souvenirs d'enfance
mais les eaux sont de plus en plus
critiquée par les défenseurs de la cause
animale conserver des animaux sauvages
en captivité n'aurait aucun intérêt
pédagogique dénonce les militants qui se
demandent également si le travail de
réintroduction des espèces est vraiment
efficace
enfin peut-on parler de bien-être pour
des animaux maintenue loin de leur
milieu naturel avec nous pour en
débattre collombat de la panoz vous êtes
directrice générale déléguée du zoo de
thoiry et juliette snit heures vous êtes
élus europe ecologie les verts de
guyancourt bonsoir mesdames colombe de
la paix mais je me tourne vers vous
pourquoi est-ce important aujourd'hui
d'avoir des au jeu mia aujourd'hui plus
que jamais c'est très important d'avoir
des parcs zoologiques parce que le
public est complètement déconnecté de la
nature beaucoup d'enfants grandissent
dans les villes et quand ils viennent au
parc ils sont reconnectées avec un
environnement complètement différent
ils apprennent à aimer les animaux et le
respect de la nature ça passe d'abord
par l'empathie par l'amour et donc c'est
très important d'avoir ce lien
aujourd'hui parce qu'on voit bien que
sur le plan écologique
enfin j'ai pas besoin d'énumérer tous
les problèmes qu'il y a mais la
sensibilisation et le rôle premier d'un
parc zoologique
on va en parler en tout cas c'est ce
lien avec la nature qui est important de
maintenir grâce à ces parcs zoologiques
juliette hinter justement vous me disiez
en préparant cette émission que vous
avez des souvenirs à thoiry et ans est
un enfant mais quand même vous avez des
réserves
quelles sont elles effectivement je
retombe de réserve mon la première comme
vous veniez de dire c'est
est ce que est ce que les eaux
permettent réellement de sauvegarder les
espèces en voie de disparition
je ne sais pas on va en parler la
deuxième réserve
c'est effectivement la formation au
public oui les habitants les français
les parisiens et on va dire des saint
quentinois se sont déconnectés de la
nature
mais est ce que l es dans un zoo permet
réellement de se reconnecter la nature
je suis pas certaine parce que c'est une
nature qui est dévoyée c'est pas la
nature telle qu'elle devrait être cédée
animaux qui sont en cage qui sont pas
dans l'environnement dans leur
environnement naturel et ça devient
chiant des animaux objets des animaux
qui bat qu'ils sont mignons des gros
nounours et on a envie d'en faire un
câlin on va acheter une peluche à la
sortie c'est de la consommation et c'est
pas forcément la même nature tels cas de
vraie tête et de cette manière les
enfants apprennent pas forcément à
respecter le vivant le
comment comme il se doit les animaux
finalement comme des objets comme des
peluches suivante un mot là-dessus
collombat alors justement bon ça dépend
beaucoup de la manière dont sont
présentés les animaux il faut
effectivement présenté les animaux dans
un milieu naturel
il faut effectivement ne pas les
apprivoiser les laisser le plus sauvage
possible et ça c'est tout un
apprentissage pour les enfants parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y à un public
consommateurs qui arrivent dans un parc
zoologique qui voudrait voir tout tout
de suite qui voudraient pouvoir caresser
les animaux et non c'est pas possible
parce que justement on les laisse
sauvage et ça on leur explique
on a des ateliers pédagogiques pour les
classes qu'on fait en lien d'ailleurs
avec l'éducation nationale
mais surtout il quand il voit les
animaux dans un environnement naturel
ils apprennent que bel animal parfois il
se cache parce qu'il n'a pas envie
d'être vu il se met à l'ombre et semer
dans un arbre qu'il faut le chercher il
faut apprendre à regarder la nature ça
se respecte ça se mérite de voir les
animaux et les animaux gardés content
des comportements comme s'ils étaient
dans leur milieu naturel et où tafer et
on apprend et ça ça fait partie de
l'apprentissage justement des gens qui
viennent dans un parc comme touahri où
il ya des grands espaces où on les voit
dans un milieu qui est justement très
naturel qui est pas en cage
alors c'est sûr que c'est moins facile
de voir les animaux mais ça fait partie
de l'apprentissage
justement je vais l'être sanitaire on a
progressé quand même sur les eaux depuis
le 20e siècle maintenant se sont
défaussés il ya plus de cage il ya plus
de choses aberrantes qu'on avait pu voir
au début donc on va quand même 20 le zoo
moderne aujourd'hui quand même plus
respectueux n'en de 2 du bien-être
animal si on peut le zoom moderne
il ya quand même beaucoup beaucoup de
jeux en réseau dans le monde il ya des
hommes modernes en dominant pas
effectivement thoiry et plutôt un son
moderne
pour autant s'ils sont pas c'est pas des
animaux en liberté
les lions les tigres sont dans des
enclos plutôt petit on voit les on les
voit faire des longueurs largeur
longueur d'argent dans la nature on a
l'impression qu'ils s'ennuient dans la
nature il faut pas ça et d'ailleurs ces
animaux si on les lâche est directement
dans l'environnement naturel d'où ils
sont censés venir il survivrait pas
parce qu'il s'appuie chat c'est parce
qu'ils savent plus se défendre ils ont
pu les instincts de survie ils savent
plus enseigner à leurs petits la chasse
la survie donc c'est des animaux qui
sont qui certes restent des animaux pour
les grands prédateurs qui reste
dangereux des animaux sauvages mais qui
n'ont plus leur instinct qui sont plus
capables de se réadapter à leur
environnement
alors justement ça nous amène à cette
voie là c'est problématique de la
réinsertion des espèces mais avant on va
peut-être parler de la cour servent à
sion ça me paraît plus logique d'abord
d'aborder l'aspect conservation
aujourd'hui en quoi ça consiste
comment vous faites comment vous
sélectionnez les espèces menacées que
vous décidez que voilà de prolonger leur
d'abord c'est ça c'est bien lee hsien
union internationale pour la
conservation de la nature qui est
appliquée sont les priorités en termes
d'espèces menacées
et ça ça
c'est ensuite retransmis au niveau de
l'association européenne des zoos qui
émis des recommandations au parc
zoologique en termes de priorités de
conservation mais la conservation c'est
pas que la réintroduction la nature
d'abord il ya beaucoup d'espèces ou la
réintroduction c'est pas du tout une
option les conditions dans le milieu
naturel ne permettent pas ça et donc ça
ne fonctionnerait pas est ce que c'est
ce qu'évoquait julias knitter sûr sûr
sûr l'aspect comportemental à l'arrière
deux choses il ya la possibilité il ya
l'impossibilité d'un certain cas parce
qu'il ya du braconnage et de la
destruction de l'habitat ya tout un ted
journal qui font que voilà le milieu où
il ya des espèces invasives parce que ça
on n'en parle pas souvent mais les
espèces invasives c'est un gros problème
dans le milieu naturel qui rentrent en
compétition qui sont problématiques pour
la survie des animaux dans leur milieu
naturel
si on prend les escargots de particules
a par exemple on a élevé pendant une
quinzaine d'années à thoiry on avait six
espèces différentes dont quatre étaient
éteintes dans le milieu naturel et qu'
on ne pouvait pas reproduire
réintroduire pendant plusieurs années
parce qu'il y avait une espèce invasive
d'escargots américains qui avaient été
introduits en polynésie pour des raisons
de gestion développera pas deux fois
exactement et qui font que ben voila
c'était plus possible maintenant il ya
quand même
alors ça marche pour certaines espèces
et des espèces effectivement juliette à
raison qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
compliqués à gérer c'est les carnivores
parce que les carnivores alors ils
perdent pas leur instinct mais par
contre ce qu'ils perdent c'est l'heure
on va dire que c'est comme si on
demandait à quelqu'un qui est pas
athlètes de faire
les jeux olympiques ils sont plus aussi
jeux sportifs on va dire entre
guillemets et moi de ce que j'enseigne à
priori que cinq espèces sauvages en
danger qui ont été réintroduites dans la
nature il ya le bison d'europe il ya
loris il ya une oie il ya le cheval de
j'ai vraiment gaulle y voit là est une
espèce de serre c'est que des herbivores
c'est tous les autres animaux on a
essayé de relâcher des lions ont déjà
venu en solo il n'ya pas très bas très
longtemps ça a été un énorme échec
et pour revenir à la la préservation
donc du patrimoine génétique de ces
animaux que vous évoquez
comment est-ce qu'on peut préserver le
patrimoine génétique des animaux s'ils
sont qu'une vingtaine 30 mm une centaine
d'espèces dans un zoo le la sélection
naturelle se fait enfin venue de savez
mieux que moi
la sélection naturelle se fait à travers
un beaucoup d'animaux très large
or même entre des échanges d'un zoo à un
autre c'est que quelques espèces qui
s'échangent c'est des animaux qui sont
pas confrontés un milieu naturel c'est
un patrimoine génétique qui s'appauvrit
s'il n'ya pas de sélection naturelle est
au bout de plusieurs générations il ya
des dérives génétique d'ailleurs choix
qui en a eu sur le cheval avec la
couleur qui change la forme du crâne qui
change donc il y a l'animal qui était
sauvage
trois générations avant ne l'est plus
trois générations plus tard il perd ses
instincts de chasseur de d'herbivores et
tout ça et en plus son patrimoine
génétique se modifie colombo sur sur ce
point effectivement de la diversité
alors en fait hier il ya quand même
beaucoup plus d'espèces que ça pour
lesquelles ça a marché mais surtout sur
le point de la diversité de toute façon
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans un
monde de compromis les populations qui
sont en parc zoologique on va dire que
c'est des populations de sauvetage mais
aujourd'hui ces problématiques de
génétique on les rencontre exacte tout à
fait les mêmes
dans le milieu naturel parce que
l'habitat est fragmenté pour beaucoup
d'espèces parce que on a des populations
qui sont isolées qui ne peuvent pas se
rejoindre et là quelque part c'est
encore pire parce que en parc zoologique
artificiellement on essaie de compenser
cette problématique génétique
c'est-à-dire que pour chaque espèce
menacée il ya un spécialiste d'espèces
qui tient un stand book et qui va
définir qu'on va reproduire tel mal avec
des femelles ex-parti masia miroir
versité gêné quand vous avez des
populations sur le terrain qui sont
complètement fragmenté et qui ne peuvent
plus se rejoindre vous pouvez même pas
arriver à ça c'est là qu'on il faut
s'interroger sur notre rapport à
l'environnement
parce que finalement la meilleure façon
de sauvegarder une espèce c'est de
sauvegarder son environnement
c'est un animal sauvage et ce sera
toujours mieux dans son environnement
car c'est un des rôles des parcs
zoologiques
oui mais non parce qu'en fait le point
sur musique peut servir aussi les sert
souvent d'alibi aux états pour pour dire
écoutez on a les eaux c'est super on
protège à certaines espèces elles sont
bien là on regarde leur patrimoine
génétique
du coup bon ben la forêt amazonienne
on ne sait pas si grave que ça on va
moins faire attention à ça donc c'est
vraiment c'est un processus qui va pas
forcément dans le bon sens ça donne
bonne conscience ça donne bonne
conscience et du coup les états au lieu
de se mettre les uns avec les autres
pour dire voilà qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour pour lutter contre cet effet mais
ils ne font pas on choisit ce palliatif
aujourd'hui l'union internationale pour
la conservation de la nature approuvent
tout à fait la démarche des parcs
zoologiques responsable je parle parce
que la réalité c'est que une grande
partie des fonds maintenant pour
soutenir les programmes sur le terrain
vient justement du travail qu'ils
effectuent un parc zoologique et que les
petites associations les arrive pas tout
seul si elles sont pas financés par les
fonds et donc je reviens à dont vous
participer au financement
évidemment de programmes sur le terrain
dans l'ana tout à fait et donc je
reviens à cette question primordiale
donc du parc zoologique avec laquelle
j'ai commencé c'est cette question de
sensibilisation parce que quand les gens
aiment les animaux ils sont plus aptes à
donner
et quand il voit enfin jeudi à loin des
yeux loin du coeur
donc on veut attirer l'attention sur la
faune on leur présente la faune parce
que là on établit un lien affectif et
les humains il marche comme ça ils sont
sur l'affectif gillett slater dernier si
on arrive à la à la fin de ce débat sur
sur ce rapport ce lien
l'anglais un autre rapport à l'animal
notre apport de prédation un d'animal
animal comme animal de compagnie
l'animal comme
comme divertissement les hommes et sont
aussi les cires que la chasse la corrida
c'est des animaux qui sont mis en scène
pour être utilisé le rapport affectif il
se fait moyens dans ces conditions là
c'est par rapport à ceux actifs qui se
construit autour de l'art et du respect
de la vie et du respect de l'animal donc
est il
peut-être qu'il faudrait trouver des
solutions pour apprendre à aimer les
animaux mais pas comme un loisir mais
comme un être vivant qui mérite tout le
respect qui lui est dû
en deux ans on vraiment on doit conclure
ces deux mois et on peut pas comparer
les présentations d'animaux comme dans
des circonvolutions impacté sur le
comportement naturel un animal et on va
lui faire faire d'autres choses on
dévoie complètement le comportement
qu'une présentation où justement on
s'efforce de se laisser les animaux de
plus sauvage possible et je dirais quand
même que dans la nature là où il ya des
sanctuaires de réserves naturelles etc
il y à des zones de présentation des
animaux très souvent parce que malgré
tout ça passe par l'affect pour les
humains
très bien merci tout les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat donc aimons nos
animaux c'est quand même la leçon de ce
soir merci et à mardi prochain
[Musique]